NASA has captured the tallest tornado on
the sun this thing is huge it was
swirling and growing for three days got
to a height of 120
000 kilometers that's almost as big as
14 Earths before collapsing into a gas
cloud this solar twirl ramped up to
speeds of 500 000 kilometers per hour
that's one thousand times faster than
the fastest tornado on earth
these plasma tornadoes usually reach
hellish temperatures if the temperature
on the sun is 5500 degrees well these
things get up to 250 000 degrees if you
got caught in one of these you'd burn
and get Torn to Pieces in seconds after
three days of rampaging on the sun This
Tornado collapsed into a gas cloud and
ejected solar material out into space
we're just lucky it didn't cause a solar
flare massive enough to hit Earth